karapika had a childhood friend named
pyro pyro was promptly murdered and
dismembered by the phantom troop now
pyro lives in a jar above the throne of
4th prince saradnik say hello to pyro
everyone and excuse the expression but
should karapika see this he is going to
lose his head hello and welcome to the
new world review source for everything
anime and manga my name is liam and i
have interesting things to say about
stuff and today that stuff is a rather
shocking discovery and deep dive into
togashi's plans for karapika and the
succession war because it is all here
right in front of our eyes also in front
of our eyes are other eyes staring back
at us disturbingly from their funky
preservative jars so of course it's all
going to begin with a quick round of
krapika cursed chamber a very simple
mini game the rules of which are as
follows karapika has descended into pure
darkness and has captured three of the
spiders responsible for his eternal
misery and it's going to be your job to
guess which one he places a nen curse on
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to form a nen val by
subscribing to the new world review
which will also result in consistent
injections of hunter-based culture
administered directly into your youtube
feed and if you are correct then you
will receive a withering stare from
karapika as he contemplates cursing you
as well so which troop member will it be
a b or the third one make your choice
now when we shall reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it was feitan or
little man thing but if you chose
incorrectly then you know the thing to
do and please do say hi in the comments
below if you are a new member of our
association welcome right though so
we've established the hypothesis that
this head in a jar sitting profoundly
above another head not in a jar is pyro
but initially we run into a slightly
important question which is who is pyro
and why do i care and this is one of
those situations where i wouldn't blame
either anime watchers or margaritas for
not remembering this character in the
2011 anime he is shown in episode 58 for
a handful of seconds and never named and
the mainline manga doesn't get much
better because he's only ever shown in
two panels although to be fair one of
those panels does at least have his name
but the bulk of information we have
concerning pyro comes from the special
hunter hunter volume zero which consists
of two chapters entitled kerapika's
memories which take us through
karapika's memories funny that but in
this we become very familiar with the
young pyro who was also a member of the
kodaklan and there are several layers of
tragedy concerning him the first is that
in an attempt to save karapika from
falling off a cliff pyro in an event
that i can only describe as somehow
actually ended up severely injuring both
his legs and his eyes a very interesting
combination of bodily things there and
dies of course being a very important
aspect of any kurt clan member so let's
not blast past that yet it will become
relevant later but this is what provided
krapika with the motivation to travel to
the outside world he wanted to find some
sort of medicine to cure pyro and look
long story less long that is why krapika
ended up outside of the village when the
phantom troop massacred the rest of the
clan so in a very like very twisted way
pyro's original tragedy paved the way
for a second tragedy as karapika was
saddled with the self-given task of
vengeance for his clan but we do learn
later on that part of this drive is to
recover the parts of pyro that were
taken and i should also note that this
material is incorporated as part of the
film hunter hunter phantom rouge but
look there's all sorts of like weird
non-canon stuff mixed in as well because
the plot heavily features a modern day
pyro doll sort of thing and apparently
it's an alternate retelling of york new
city that togashi had originally planned
but look there's a reason why it was
scrapped so let's just let's move on
back to relevant things now the next
question you may have is hey new old guy
yeah sure that head looks vaguely like
pyro but why would anyone go to the
trouble of keeping the head when the
only valuable thing about the curt clan
are the scarlet eyes well this question
is answered incredibly briefly even
forgettably in the manga during york
knew when krapika is infiltrating the
strat family he is presented with a test
and of course in a moment of great
traumatic irony his test is to acquire a
set of scarlet eyes now in the 2011
anime we see a shot of eyes and jars and
that's it but the manga goes into
slightly more detail because krapika's
instructions to acquire the eyes were as
follows curta eyeballs must be scarlet a
complete set with head preferred
difficulty level a so we do know that
for whatever reason there were cases
where entire curta heads were harvested
although given that currently in the
manga every set of scarlet eyes has been
accounted for we also know that this
head here sitting as the centerpiece of
sradnik's disgusting body part
collection is a one of a kind it is the
only head with a complete set of scarlet
eyes in the entire world so we've
established that this is definitely a
curta head but why is this pyro well to
answer that we need to engage in a bit
of narrative dumbing down firstly we
have met a lot of kurt clan members
mostly in volume zero none of which have
pyro's bowl cut hair style secondly as
we have a direct comparison to sirenix
head this curtain noggin clearly belongs
to a child and thirdly i know that
togashi sometimes forgets or let's be
real completely disregards plot points
that he set up but i find it very
difficult to believe that even he would
deliberately design a completely
separate curta clan childhood that just
so happens to look exactly like someone
dramatically relevant like say pyro is
it possible
i guess is it likely though
i don't think so here's the real kicker
though we also know for a fact that
pyro's body was harvested because in
chapter 344 after discovering where the
last of the eyes are karapika states but
this will soon end this is the last
monster with the last of the eyes among
them pyro so pyro is definitely part of
saradnick's collection and i would
personally find it really odd if he
happened to be two of the lone eyeballs
as opposed to the head in the center
that looks exactly like him i mean to be
fair tagashi has done weirder things in
the past he's unpredictable and he
sometimes does so confusion for the sake
of confusion but until that happens i
think we need to go with the occam's
razor explanation because the simplest
one is usually the correct one either
way what i'm really interested in is why
pyro's head was kept intact as opposed
to the other kurta members and i would
posit that it likely has something to do
with his aforementioned eye injury
whoever was harvesting the eyes may have
picked up on this and decided that it
would be too risky to remove them from
the head or perhaps that injury had the
sickening effect of somehow making
pyro's eyes even more special in some
sort of way so they decided to keep them
in the head as a sort of super special
collector's edition which once again is
a sickening thought but that's the way
you need to think about these kind of
characters in fact whenever the topic of
body part collecting comes up in hunter
hunter i'm always reminded of karapika's
words in chapter 67. there are two
things collectors want one is rare and
valuable items the other is friends to
whom they can brag about their
collection which brings us to the ever
important saradnik even before this pyro
thought was brought up the fourth prince
of the khaking empire was clearly being
set up as a direct photographical you
know they're both nen geniuses both
interested in scarlet eyes and they are
of course both floppy mop-headed blondes
it's as good a match as we will ever see
and with karapika directly representing
an opposing prince in the succession war
this conflict was going to happen
eventually and i guess we should also
take a moment to remind everyone that
ceranic's entire collection is indeed
aboard the black whale one because the
khaking empire are treating this voyage
as a permanent move their intention is
to settle on the dark continent and
develop an even more powerful nation
with all of the benefits that the dark
continent can provide them so very
interestingly both krapika and pyro were
in the same place at the same time for
the first time in many units of time
what's unclear at this stage is if
krapika knows that pyro's whole head
remains intact in fact the entire
harvesting process is rather thankfully
unclear but if i was writing a story i
feel like maximum drama would be
achieved if krapika did not know and
then suddenly he was confronted with the
preserved image of his best friend and i
have no doubt that this would throw him
into a rage the likes of which we have
never seen which is going to end up like
a domino effect into even more drama
because the other story thread being set
up here is krapika's loyalty and duty to
prince wobile and it may even come down
to an ultimate choice between closure
for the kurt clan and securing the
safety of wobel and in that case what
would he prioritize vengeance for those
long past or the future for someone
whose time has barely begun it's a rough
choice for sure but then again that kind
of summarizes kraupker's entire
existence and whatever the case this is
very much set up to be his character
climax in the series to add to all of
the stuff we also mustn't forget that
the phantom troop are also aboard the
blackwell one and while karapika has
theoretically left that revenge quest to
die we do still have hints of this
thread potentially becoming important
specifically from zodiac member
mizeistom who very much struggled with
the decision of whether or not to tell
krapika about their presence and if this
was any other series then i would take
this as a definite piece of
foreshadowing however as per usual this
is hunter hunter and togashi could just
be playing out the realistic thoughts of
mizeistom without any intention of doing
something grander with them to act as
more of a character study of mizeistom
than having him just opine for the sake
of story and the narrative and the stuff
and while i don't necessarily agree with
this next thought i do feel the need to
mention it because whenever this whole
pyro head business is brought up there
is another sub theory that emerges
stating that pyro's head could be
incorporated into sradnik's guardian nen
beast and to be fair the head within a
head does look very like very vaguely
like the pyro with shaped head in the
jar but this is where the gaping logic
chasm just becomes a bit too much of a
leap for me mostly because this nan
beast is designed to explore an entirely
different idea this is radnick's
manifestation of women in his life or at
least his feelings towards women in his
life who seem to exist to be butchered
and their remains transformed into fine
art and i do think that this head could
just as easily belong to this woman who
we saw into his hotel room to continue
to be fair though sradnik did not choose
the form of this nen beast it was
manifested as part of the sidon ceremony
so perhaps if pyro's head is so
important to the fourth prince it is the
centerpiece of his collection after all
then its image may also have been
incorporated into the guardian nen beast
and i have to say that would also be
quite dramatic for karapika to come face
to face with the head of his childhood
friend trapped within this greater like
horrific monster thing once again though
it's just a step too far for me
everything about this nin b so far has
been very much geared towards women even
its abilities which thus far have only
targeted women to add to that in the
rare other images we have of the head
within another head the haircut appears
to be much less similar to that of pyro
and more of a central part than a clean
bowl cut so i think that pyro's head
remains here and here alone and you know
with all of this head talk we haven't
even begun to discuss the radnick's
throne this thing is like pure
necromancy although i do love the heads
on either side of ceratnic because they
look like your classical devil and angel
on each shoulder style of situation
forever trying to talk ceradnik into
doing stupid things i think you should
show everyone your penis my lord you
know usually i disagree with that guy
but i think that's a good idea hmm do it
my lord yeah look i i don't see why not
do it do it do it do it theta i've made
a decision
you know that would actually explain
quite a bit about sirednik but i suppose
the real question we're left with is the
outcome right now krapika has done
everything he can on his quest to avoid
murdering someone except for the one guy
that he murdered but ever since then
he's made a career of threatening
tricking and bargaining with people to
retrieve the eyes of his clan members
but something tells me that none of
those methods are quite going to work
with saratnik and after seeing pyro's
head i'm really not too sure that
karapika will be in any sort of
bargaining mood either however he will
be in the mood for another video like
this one which is also about hunter
hunter because there's always more to
learn exploring experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there